the career and the work that you've done
being in the business having success is
idealized by a lot of people totally and
um so you can think
uh you know I remember one of the first
things when I first got into the
business
um especially on camera someone gave me
some advice never complain never get
never be caught complaining and I
thought oh that's true
um once we had the author Frank McCord
on who's this you know great Irish
writer Who had who wrote Angela's Ashes
and he talks about his terrible
upbringing you know and literally being
impoverished and he he'd written these
amazing Works about his really tough
childhood and
in in Ireland in like the 1930s and 40s
and I remembered we we had him on the
show and the show's over and we had just
a really tough long string of shows
in a row and I walked out and I'm
pulling my tie off and went oh my gosh
man this
this gig sometimes just really gets to
me and I forgot who I was talking to I'm
talking to Frank McCourt the guy who
is famous for writing about his
impoverished childhood in Ireland anyway
but there was a lot of other [ __ ]
people who'd be willing to do it if
you'd want to give it up a Conan and I'm
like no no no Mr McCord no I'm I know
I'm so happy that I you know because I
immediately I you know here I am with my
makeup on yeah right wearing a suit
jacket and I've just chatted and done
some banter and been very highly
compensated for it and I said oh man
this job sometimes ah you're feeling
like you're a little sick and tired of
your job are you you know like and I
thought Jesus Christ but the times I've
been around especially uh single camera
I'm I'm I'm
and I had a little bit of experience
with it a couple of months ago uh and I
was stunned
at how much how hard everybody's working
yeah really I mean the hours are long
and stuff yeah and not just the ACT I
mean the actors are there but then
anyone the crew the people the people in
makeup are there so the actors are
showing up at like five and six in the
morning but the the people in hair and
makeup are showing up at 4 30 in the
morning to get everything ready for them
and they're packing up after the actors
go home
I just was blown away and now I look at
um these single camera shows and movies
very differently I think
wait a minute every shot I'm seeing
there were it was done 55 different ways
yeah and it took five months for like
four minutes of footage with some of
these big ones you know I mean it it's
it's a behemoth Enterprise and it really
is like it's an amazing thing to be a
part of and I I you know I agree with
you about this uh
complaining is
in in in in this industry is it's many
things and it's definitely a bad look
um
I I think the you know the only time
that I'm um
forthcoming or or transparent about
about about the processes is more of
like as a witness to help people
to not idealize it in a way that is sort
of like I don't know it just it just
leads to more and more fantasy you know
what I mean it's like I personally
love what I do and I'm also constantly
taking stock of like it's you know the
the the the the culture of the industry
it's just yeah it's like really really
intense I think the a good way to put it
because this is you're bringing up a
good point which is Tim uh in my opinion
um you need to love it you need to love
it and I think uh and I've talked about
this a bunch on this podcast but I meet
younger people who sometimes are
interested in what I'm doing because
they love comedy and I think great
they're willing to like give it your
absolutely yeah all yeah and I I always
say are you are you willing to feed like
remove your leg and feed it into a wood
chipper to to to do this because you
love it that much and
uh if the answer is yes then you have
your answer I do think uh it gets
complicated especially in this
influencer world we live in now where
people are looking for what they have
idealized is the gravy that comes with
it and they're not thinking about is
this really are you are you up for the
work and also are you up for an
incredible amount of disappointment are
you up for humiliation rejection
rejection
um and uh are you are you up for yeah
people liking you and being excited to
see you and also people not liking you
and and letting you know it and if you
are then great but uh you have to be
open to all of that and to me that's
about really loving it and I think
that's how people survive I think you
and I both know people who've
gone into this because they thought
if I get famous this will cure
this will be the sav and the ointment
that will cure my insecurities the fact
that I was a nerd the fact that no one
the the girl I like didn't pay attention
to me this will cure all of those wounds
and I know people that felt that way got
famous it didn't that didn't happen it
doesn't fix if you've got a hole inside
you you still have that hole and they
become enraged about it they're Furious
yeah they're rich and recognizable and
they're really angry because it didn't
fix
the thing that they wanted to fix and
again at that point it's like there's
some
at that point the hill is really
tall yeah and the peak is very far away
because yeah I mean also you know again
and and I hope in this context is clear
like not at all complaining about it
it's it's like bearing witness to this
reality we know that like
Fame and wealth how many more
documentaries about are the world's
biggest icons and most talented people
who've got how many more do we need to
see who've fallen and collapsed like you
know like like dead stars or whatever
it's real it's you know it's like it's
again it just helps us understand the
forces of work like let's
certainly never be ungrateful and then
like let's not paper over how it's uh uh
I think particularly the fame aspect
which that is like a is like a kind of a
modern
human phenomenon and that is a really
interesting thing to be witnessed to and
to to learn about human psychology in
that way I I find that kind of um what I
wanted to or not it's it's endlessly
fascinating you know and and
um it's its own
it's its own kind of
Paul of mirrors you can't look too long
into it but it's like if you develop a
discipline with peering in and and and
and kind of gleaning some things and
then
stepping away you know that I I think
it's uh
it's really I I do I I I love what I do
and I can continue to love the things
that I'm learning even as I uh am very I
try to be all the time very clear about
like how
you know uh I'm trying to I don't want
to say something Sensational how you
know it's like everything you were just
saying I mean just everything you were
saying well how about how about this how
about I'll say that everything has a
cost yeah so that's good yeah it's uh
there you there's always a cost so and
there's a cost to everything and so you
just need to be reasonable and you need
to see both sides of it and and weigh
them yeah and sometimes if the cost gets
too high
um you need to track that as well and uh
I I think the big antidote something
you've done I've done is
find your partner
have kids that is huge and then invest
in that because
um uh the rest of it will come and go
but
um my wife assures me she will never
leave me
and I I make her renew that vow every
day
you think she's on the way out
all it takes is one one face hold I know
that's right I'm watching way too many
Gossip Girls these days
[Laughter]
it's also you know in this my
son holding and holding it still yeah
while you say things like I'm gonna hold
your face right here so that you have to
so I can mansplain something to you I
wouldn't I wouldn't like that has Tak
ever held your face I've never held my
face he's never been like you know what
about this what about the what about the
I do that to myself
feline you make that face when you do it
I do this yeah I I make kind of a weird
pouting face as I stroke my own chin
that's weird it got me through fifth
sixth seventh grade okay so don't do it
in class like sometimes the teacher
would say Conan stop that and I go
it's a podcast
[Laughter]